letzte woche hat janosch ein neues video
gemacht und das ist so gut angekommen
dass wir ihn direkt nochmal losschicken
hier ist ja noch hallo janosch die amish
geht gleich raus und unser thema heute
ist mensch sein
wir möchten menschen darüber reden was
für menschen sie sind und einfach mal
gucken was sie darauf antworten los
geht's
[Musik]
was sind sie für ein mensch ein guter
mensch der welt offen hoffentlich
fröhlich und genießt das leben ein
lustiger mensch was sind sie für ein
mensch kleiner ausblick
ich bin sehr ausgeglichen würde ich
sagen nein
lebensfroh ein netter mensch
ein normaler hat das gleiche ein
fröhlicher mensch ein cooler mensch ich
bin ein hoffentlich herzensguter offener
und fröhlicher mensch der das leben
genießt und gerne aber auch anpackt
arbeitet und leckeres eis macht und was
zeichnet dich aus was zeichnet sie aus
spontanität der dicke behaupten kämpfen
ich arbeite viel freiwillig
geduld ja vielleicht mein humor toleranz
[Musik]
frage ehrlichkeit spontaneität und
selbstironie immer gelassen zu bleiben
ich glaube ich bin sehr ausgeglichen
also ich bin fröhlich aber trotzdem
arbeite ich gern und hart und
ich bin ein freund des lebens also ich
genieße genieße das leben und was sind
deine stärken
ich kann gut mit menschen dann kann
glaube ich relativ gut kommunizieren
ich bin gutmütig und was sind ihre
stärken
[Musik]
kann ich spontan nicht sozusagen
zielstrebigkeit genauigkeit laut sein
argumentieren dass meine stärken dass
ich anpacken kann und trotzdem aber auch
dass die gewisse portion leidenschaft
mitbringen und spaß an der arbeit habe
und was macht sie glücklich
liebe ich bin gerade vater geworden
gratulation deswegen bin ich sehr
glücklich momentan das wetter und wir
sind hierher geflogen der flug von
saarbrücken hierher nach berlin über die
ferien in berlin
meine kinder und meine familie dass ich
in berlin lebe ich auch
über mein leben über meinen verlobten
[Gelächter]
dass ich die sonne genießen kann
in berlin zu sein dass der sommer in
berlin so wunderbar ist wir haben 30
grad den ganzen tag schon seit april ist
eigentlich sommer und es scheint so
weiterzugehen und dafür bin ich dankbar
wirklich und was mögen sie gerne meine
familie ehrlichkeit
essen sommer sonne und strand
am liebsten mag ich natürlich heiß und
es ist dann auch selber
ansonsten surf ich liebend gern das geht
in berlin natürlich schlecht aber das
passt dann ganz gut mit dem eis laden
zusammen hat im winter zu und dann kann
ich die welt bereisen und wellenreiten
und was magst du nicht so gern erdnüsse
was ich nicht mag ist wenn man
[Musik]
und pünktlich ist das mag ich nicht
im streit mit
streiten zur schule gehen
unehrlichkeit wenn leute das leben zu
ernst nehmen
heiße suppe die rechtsextremen
schlafmangel was mache ich nicht so
gerne an
nur arbeiten also wenn ich jeden tag
zwei stunden arbeiten muss dann wird es
zu viel
also man braucht denn man braucht den
ausgleich und was machst du gerne an dir
meine haare
meine beine
ich mag gerne dass ich und ich bin meine
zuverlässigkeit die ehrlichkeit und ja
die spontaneität und dass ich gerne
lache das ich habe und gerne lachen
das weiß ich nicht dass ich so offen bin
ich verstehe mich mit jedem gut also
mein bauch meine augen an mir selbst
arbeiten
ich mag dass sich eismacher bin und ein
schönes produkt vor dezember das finde
ich toll
und wie wurden sie zu dem was sie sind
das ist eine schwierige frage
durch die eltern einfach meine ziele
verfolgen
ja ich muss sagen einfach mal selber
sein also vertrauen
durch ja wahrscheinlich ehrgeiz und
unterstützung von meinen eltern durch
meine eltern und freunde und wer hat
durch die menschen die ich kenne
bestimmt vor allem durch meine eltern
haben mir viel gutes vorgelebt und
ansonsten hat berlin mich sicherlich
geprägt und viele auslandserfahrungen
auch die mich stück für stück auch immer
auch durch neue sprachen und das
erlernen neuer neuer kulturen und
kennenlernen neuer menschen immer wieder
auch geprägt haben diese werde ich ja
durch die eltern durch richtige
entscheidungen an den richtigen stellen
hoffentlich vielleicht auch falsche
entscheidungen weiß man ja nie so genau
und jetzt seid ihr dran schreibt uns in
die kommentare was für ein typ mensch
seid ihr beantwortet die frage für euch
selbst wir freuen uns auf eure antworten
und wir freuen uns euch kennen zu lernen
und gleichzeitig könnt ihr wie jede
woche noch interaktive übungen machen
ihr bekommt das vokabular zu dieser
episode bekommt verschiedene ausdrücke
und grammatik die in dieser episode
benutzt wurde und das ganze könnt ihr
üben wenn ihr ein mitglied von easy
german werdet das geht hier klickt
einfach auf den link dort findet ihr
alles was ihr wissen müsst ihr könnt ihr
sie german abonnieren solltet ihr
unbedingt machen und wir sehen uns
nächste woche schon wieder
bis bald